the American Christmas Tree Association
says more than three-quarters of
American households put up a tree every
year about 80% of those are artificial
now that's an increase of more than 30%
since 1992 and this year a million
dollar campaign is trying to convince
you to buy real Christmas trees this
year
Nikki batise is at balsam Hill holiday
shop that's in New Jersey
Nikki good morning good morning about 30
million real Christmas trees are sold in
the US every year but artificial trees
have become increasingly popular since
they were created in the 1880s just take
a look at these two trees next to me
it's hard to tell which is real which is
fake and which can bring more holiday
joy to your home so we're looking at how
many trees on all this land 65,000 trees
on 65 acres that's unbelievable
how many are ready to say have between
five and six thousand trees ready for
sale this year
oh these Mary Mary real Christmas trees
the Douglas fir is generally six to
seven seven to eight feet tall are not
just filling John Wyckoff seven
generation 170 acre farm what are you
guys doing out here today
they're also lighting up homes and
hearts during the holidays I think it's
the memories I think it's the the joy of
you know hearing milani or Daniella
saying we're gonna cut our tree it
what would a Christmas be without a real
Christmas tree a choice the Christmas
tree promotion boards million dollar
social media campaign there's so many to
choose from it's fighting to preserve
by encouraging Americans to keep it real
so we're just getting our tree for this
year we came here last year and he
proposed which is lovely so we got a
small little tradition going to anyone
who's thinking about going to buy an
artificial tree what do you say to them
I wouldn't give my wife fake roses on
Valentine's Day why would you want to
have an artificial Christmas tree in
your house in 2017 Americans bought more
than 27 million real Christmas trees we
plan for 7 to 10 years down the road
because that's how long it takes us to
grow a Christmas tree during the
recession 10 years ago farmers planted
fewer trees that means this year supply
is below demand which has boosted
business and prices a real tree like
this on average will cost you about $75
or for anywhere from nine to nineteen
thousand dollars you can buy an
artificial tree like this one and it'll
last you a lifetime there's a bit of a
real or fake Christmas competition going
on about 80 percent of US households put
up artificial trees we'd like to have an
artificial tree because I have allergies
so we've had them our whole life
the artificial tree is so convenient
they don't have bugs you put them up and
you're set balsam Hill has everything
you need to make this season price
artificial tree companies like balsam
Hill are also stepping up their
marketing and tech game this is just
this section and it goes right down in
there and as soon as it goes in it
lights up Mac Harmon created balsam Hill
in 2006 when he was disappointed with
the fake tree options one of the great
things about is it comes pre lit which
is a huge advantage but also you don't
have to water it you don't have to sweep
up the needles but Harmon also enjoys
real Christmas trees and says above all
it's about the holiday spirit
I think anything that helps promote
Christmas trees really helps our
Christmas tree industry fewer families
are setting up Christmas trees each year
and so what I like about keep it real is
it's really focused on a younger
demographic and getting them excited
about going out to a Christmas tree farm
and having that experience that this is
a family tradition that we do
gather if you're really torn over real
or fake one solution is to join the 11
percent of Americans like my mom who by
both biana we're all about the real ones
right it's all about the smell
trying to figure out what a $19,000
artificial tree looks like Nicki but
thanks we'll be right back